Universities are often cited as
mythologies of the modern era,
Superman,
spiderman,
wonder woman,
and the hulk.
These are the new gods,
the site and Apollo Zeus of our debt,
but the strongest similarities between
Greek myth and American comics have less
to do with the characters or their
supernatural powers than with an ever
growing interweaving tapestry of story.
There will be very little force,
for example,
in escalas is Oresteia the story of
arrestees revenge on his mother
Clytemnestra murder of her husband
agamemnon arrestees father.
If the story of Agamemnon had not
already been told in homer's Iliad,
the dark family history of Agamemnon is
assumed in escalates.
His tragedy all at symbolisms of rape,
murder and incest.
Augment the RSD is expansion of it.
That same idea goes for Frank Miller's.
The dark knight returns,
the new orange tail of a geriatric
Batman coming out of retirement.
Miller drew on what was then 48 years of
Batman stories from Bob Kane to Dennis
O'neil from sixties camp to seventies,
brooding.
All of it informs the Dark Knight
returns introspective depiction of a
beast at war with the man who embodies
them,
both stories,
drug depth from the narrative universes
to which they belong,
more depth in either could achieve
alone,
and the stories that came after use
these in the same way.
This is a unique feature of mythology.
Every story lends special weight to
every other.
Shared characters develop a life's worth
of pain,
triumph,
anxiety,
affection,
and as the tapper street grows,
larger and tighter,
individual threads become more sensitive
to effects on others and the whole.
It's why we keep returning to Greek
myth.
It's why we love comic books and when it
comes to film,
Marvel comics understands with ironman
the incredible hulk captain America,
the first Avenger and thor marvel rolled
out and incredible and incredibly
successful campaign to entwine it's
heroes world.
The first phase,
as they called it,
featured origin stories.
Unnecessary hurdle.
Average filmgoers weren't familiar with
thor or ironman.
Then with the groundwork laid in a
number of hints that something bigger
was on the way marvel studios delivered
the avengers,
the first shared universe comic film.
It's hard to overstate the impact of
this under the guidance of Sweden.
The avengers came off beautifully,
but the real payoff was next with iron
man,
three marvel released a film in which
the facts of a shared universe fed back
and added special way to Tony Stark's,
new life and story.
It's something more than sql.
It's something that's never been done
before and Phil compared to this DC
comics heroes are hopelessly alone.
They exist awkwardly on separate film
islands.
Superman doesn't know Batman,
Greenland,
or does it.
No wonder woman or Martian manhunter or
Aquaman.
Nobody knows the flash.
Christopher Nolan did a superb job with
Batman begins and the dark night,
but he's got them.
City has no sister in metropolis.
Every hero is the first of its kind.
Hopefully the upcoming superman versus
Batman movie is assigned that DC
starting to get its act together.
Of course,
Dave Cast Ben Affleck,
but that's another story.
There were even rumors that a Justice
League movie,
the superior analog of the avengers,
in my opinion,
is in the cars for 2017 fingers and toes
crossed.
Who knows what phase marvel will be in.
By then,
the stories can only get deeper and more
complex.
It's a big production to fold directors
and actors and writers into a shared
universe,
but it's worth all that trouble if the
product is a whole new class of cinema.
Hey everybody.
Thanks for watching.
I'm a huge comic Book Fan and Comic Book
Movie Fan.
You might know that from some previous
videos on the DC person.
I've always read DC comics.
Superman has been my favorite superhero
forever,
so it's so painful to watch what DC is
doing in their film universe,
especially giving Zack Snyder the reigns
to superman and Batman and it just,
it it.
It pains me a lot.
If you have an idea for a topic you'd
like me to cover a write in the comments
and also I love your comments.
Keep commenting.
I'm.
I'm going to try to respond to as many
as I can.
Hopefully I can do all of them.
Thanks for watching and I'll see you
next time.